hey folks it's Sunday yeah slow day it
is you know I just kind of got up and
put up the matinee show so hope you guys
are enjoying that we have to think of
something to review for the next matinee
I know there was like a lot of
possibilities
we might review Kingdom because we've
been watching it but I'm not sure if
we're gonna have it if we're not sure if
we're gonna be able to watch the whole
entire thing
yeah I would do that yeah so we might do
something else um somebody recommend
they do um that Kurt Russell movie no
this is for the new movies for the new
movies yeah it's gotta be a new movie
yeah okay then
[ __ ] cuz we did we did reviews on all
the new movies that we saw then well
yeah that just went up today we have to
do it we do they're going that there's a
lot more stuff up there we can yeah well
like I said I wanted to do VFW because
that's yeah I'm so right on xbox
somebody recommended the platform which
is on Netflix how I think it's 2019 so
it's kind of like a sci-fi it's Spanish
I think but it's like sci-fi horror type
of thing I remember which one
yeah yeah cuz I kept seeing it like in
the new yeah [ __ ] so so we might do that
and like I said there was a couple other
ones that we cut by action movies one
guy said it wasn't any good but you know
maybe want to see it myself that was the
one where they guns akimbo yeah it looks
like good comedy to me I mean well we'll
see how it goes like I said it's you
know people's taste in movies is
subjective so I might like it you might
like it well just most movies do suck I
mean it just well I I wouldn't even go
that far like I don't think most movies
suck it's just the most movies are just
kind of like mediocre I think most
movies suck like you know I mean for
something to suck it has to be just like
oh [ __ ] this you know what I mean
whereas most of them it's like I can
watch him but then like I don't remember
anything most of them we don't even
watch I'm saying you know yeah that's
true
you know I mean so I'm counting the ones
we don't watch to most movies just suck
somebody to even go back to hook in 1987
and pick a random movie now shit's gonna
suck well yeah it's just like that's
just coming back most movies that have
been put out suck it's just that you
know that's the way it is most of
everything that comes out the books
like everything but um somebody told me
cuz I'd been seeing this movie - what
the [ __ ] is it called Vera tika there is
something like that and I had seen it I
don't remember if it's on Netflix or
shudder or something that's been dancing
movies yeah and it's like I didn't know
that Glenn Danzig had anything to do
with that I said the only reason cuz
like the guy said the movie was really
bad and I said I suspected that it was
bad because I saw Chris Stockman that he
had done like a hilarious ad review on
it yeah which he usually he does he only
does this like if the movies like really
really bad or like so bad it's good yeah
so I didn't watch the review so I don't
even know anything about the movie but I
didn't even know that Glen dance it
could anything to do with that until
somebody commented on the YouTube video
so it's like well [ __ ] now I might have
to watch still I'm going to say this
some of the best some of the best [ __ ]
well-done low-budget movies in the
genres that we've liked in the past
couple years has been Mandy in color out
of space yeah
now some people didn't like color out of
space they didn't think it worked but I
don't think they realized that the
original story that it kind of came from
kinda didn't work either it kind of
worked it was just weird you know it
wasn't a real I mean it was a faithful
adaptation but they had to kind of I
mean the story even though the story is
very short the story takes place over a
much longer period like several years so
you know what I mean so they had to add
like a characters and they had to make
it happen much quicker one guy that
reviewed it said I don't know if this is
a genius movie or if it's just not any
good so you the one of the two or sign
of a good movie that's what it was good
when it's like two extremes of like I
enjoy sure yeah I do I want to see I
want to see that director do Moza
Dunwich horror yeah yeah well yeah I
kind of hope that he gets to do it but
like I said it's you know if it's that
spectravision production company yeah if
they get you know behind I'm sure Elijah
Wood has enough money to like Nic Cage
just [ __ ] being crazy just caging the
[ __ ] out I still can't believe you
haven't seen valley girl we really had
to be you didn't see wild a party there
the David Lynch movie he's in that as
well
yeah saw that one no that's not a David
Lynch movie okay um this one was the one
where he had like that snakeskin jacket
and he was like doing he was like Elvis
fan boy
and they were doing like a road trip and
it was like a Wizard of Oz thing and
everybody loved that by me actually I
was I was gonna buy it on blu-ray but
all his movies are like really really
expect I've seen some you know I saw
comments from younger people they just
don't understand Nic Cage because you
grow up with him he's a crazy so what
happened to him what what happened to
this man that kind of [ __ ] you know no
man I'm just like it's [ __ ] Nic Cage
you know he was always just he always
played these he's a weird guy who was
who played weird characters and put his
own weird spin on characters he's
cuddling that's been glove yeah like a
slightly more mainstream version and he
was well he was more yes Morris he's
more masculine more alpha male I mean he
you know he can be mais I did like
action movie mr. Glover never really
doesn't really man up on [ __ ] yeah he's
just [ __ ] crazy you know he he's cool
I like him it was crazy for a long time
because I think people think oh nowadays
that you know that that's a new thing
I'm like go back to the 80s and watch
vampires kiss yeah he started
interacting me started off crazy
he lost all this [ __ ] money yeah so
now he'll be in he'll be in anything
because he needs the money needs the
money and he he's kind of like freed
he's like been freed from the
responsibility of being an actor he
didn't give a [ __ ] so he is crazy as
[ __ ] and it works well and that's what's
on there that's why I earn if you need
to do to act [ __ ] crazy cuz they want
some cage dication yeah and really I
think one of his I think the greatest
masterpiece he's everyone was it was
Mandy I think they just let him go full
on and that one he's just and it works
with the tone of the imagine and Matt
here you imagine Nic Cage cage and the
[ __ ] out on really bad acid and that's
literal he's on bad acid yeah and he's
the hero yeah he's the hero of the movie
yeah and he's sucking on a quest for
vengeance against evil was that weird
[ __ ] and now I can't even remember
cuz he's been in so many movies that I
thought we watched one like a few months
ago on Netflix or something like that
and he wasn't super crazy and he was
playing like a relative
normal role wasn't there something it
was like something to do with was it
incest
no was it the dog yeah yeah yeah yeah
but you know what it's what is that
movie what I think I think it did have
something to do with incest in it
right that's what was it didn't he
played some bad guy who was kind of
molesting his stepsisters his
stepdaughter see that work making a
little anus a stepdaughter and it was it
didn't know but then it turned out it
turned out his wife was trying to kill
him
and that sounds kind of familiar yeah
all I remembered was like I was you that
there was like either underage or there
was like like and yes I can't remember
if he was the perpetrator if you didn't
know or like I don't David I think they
left it think they have master I can't
was not a good I was drinking and it
wasn't a very it wasn't a very man I
can't even remember the name it wasn't a
bad move he just wasn't very memorable
at the time I was going miss it's a trip
but I forgot about it you were doing the
same thing yeah that's it yeah that's
what I mean yeah he'll be had anything
yeah I enjoyed it while I was watching
it but I can't even remember the
neighborhood better and what's weird is
that the movies that the movie study
that he's in even though he'll be in
anything tend to be all right at least
alright well yeah because I mean that's
the only he's really the only selling
point for like I mean for example he is
the only reason that I would watch any
of the [ __ ] Left Behind movies yeah
yeah yeah I mean because why the hell
would I watch any other remember that
he's the airline pilot yeah yeah that
was almost like a that was almost like a
modern-day version of Ed Wood movie that
one I feel like he almost just phoned it
in out of the way yeah he did he found
that one in because you probably didn't
want to be in it because who the [ __ ]
knows
he owed all that money yeah that's what
I use like hey you want to be in this
like apocalyptic end-of-the-world
Christian movie where everyone gets
raptured he's like yeah yeah yeah it
would have been it would have been a lot
better if he'd have been like super
crazy in it yeah they would probably let
it be crazy in it no probably not
they're like settle down and you're like
so downed it seems like some of the
stuff he's in now they've almost kind of
have written them the character around
him yeah well because I said cuz he's
got like such a dick
stink t'v acting style let's call it
that um you know what I mean so I think
nowadays he gets hired for that
particularly so that was like a really
smart thing for him to do yeah
- just like lean in - yeah weirdness and
stuff like I said just like he reminds
me a lot of like Crispin Glover because
Crispin Glover he just does like weird
[ __ ] and he does like all these [ __ ]
weird roles all the time and so that's
if you want like a weird guy that's your
go-to yeah you know what I mean you just
you have to like play to your strengths
yeah it's what I'm saying he's a true
especially in acting he's a trip you
guys haven't seen Mandy see that one
yeah I know we recommend that like every
single show it's really it's good though
it's really good yeah um yeah so hoster
in the bedroom yeah I bought yeah yeah
that for Christmas I'm telling them that
it's silk
yeah it's yes it's pretty they actually
had like a much nicer one but um like
like a cooler design like it was one
that they didn't have like in this
contract it's like another country's
poster for it but that one I didn't get
that one because it wouldn't have got
here in time it's all black with duck
and fuchsia and [ __ ] and a weird
psychedelic stuff and yeah I like some
of the posters that they do because
sometimes you have these artists that I
guess they have permission to like do
posters for movies pretty like older
ones and stuff like that but that aren't
anything like the posters that you know
that accompanied the movie when they
came out yeah yeah they're doing like
the aftermarket yeah kind of posters
like I said I guess you have to get
permission to do those but some of those
are like amazing yeah like I've there
are some really really nice ones like
what you have that one that was a thing
the thing that's like really yeah that's
really kick-ass and it's like I've seen
I have I have a shining one - yeah I
have one from profounder oh so deep red
but that one I think that I think that
was one of the posters like it's weird
because like the US posters particularly
now it will even [ __ ] you since like the
90s probably u.s. posters tend to be not
all that exciting because they're not
real art based like they used to be like
now that's just all corporate like big
floating heads like over a cityscape and
[ __ ] like that it's like Photoshop and
stuff
like you don't usually get ones that
look like a painting or that look like
some weird minimalist kind of yeah
modern stuffs all super corporate it's
been real corporate for a long like I
said at least since the 90s but um I
have noticed though like I said I guess
because you know more people are
interested in like collecting posters
and like aftermarket stuff I have
noticed that like a lot of the posters
fig-leaf or horror movies and stuff like
that are getting a lot better I think I
think the the kind of nadir of poster
design was probably like mid to late 90s
I think okay I got a feeling all that
shit's gonna go I don't think that
stuff's gonna survive I mean I think the
only thing keeping traditional movie
going
you know movie going traditions are
basically ex generation people and maybe
some boomers but it seems like younger
people Millennials and younger they
didn't really grow up with any kind of
connection to them to the movies or you
know like why do I have to watch this
here you know why can I see this on my
phone I think I just don't think I just
don't think that's a tradition that's
gonna gonna live much longer I just I
just can't see it
what could save it you know what you
know what I think might save something
like theaters and movies the drive-in
the drive-in might be they might
understand that a little bit more well
and there are still some drive-ins open
and they do like retro type of [ __ ]
because there's like a huge subsection
you know of Millennials and younger that
are into like retro [ __ ]
yeah and so your bigger cities can like
support like an indie drive is not like
a drive and then you know they would
have like a themed double triple feature
whatever
so you'd only take it's only a matter of
time before yeah you know [ __ ]
Millennials realize now I don't know
they're not as cool as us really we grew
up feral you know and didn't barely ever
saw our parents and [ __ ] you know me and
we were like on our own most of the time
but I don't know I'm not gonna share
[ __ ] young young people even have sex
anymore but that's what the [ __ ] the
drive-in was all about it was basically
just a damn motel you can see all the
damn cars bouncing well yeah cuz I look
along the back row and you [ __ ] see
your buddy down there and you
he's back there with Tracy you know the
man that car moving you know I'm [ __ ]
looking and laugh and you know it's just
it was [ __ ] wild I selected maybe
having sex in the [ __ ] backseat your
buddy's ahead but your boys having sex
with his girlfriend in the front seat
that's that's how wild that [ __ ] was
back then but I don't know I don't think
kids can handle that now this I don't
know you sound like a grandpa because
what they tease kids today rare remember
well they take they take pictures of it
yeah and you know minutes I think they'd
be too scared to do it baby I don't know
I doubt that very much all right
I grew up where I grew up in Daytona
Beach which most of you know if you have
listened to the show for any time and we
used to have one drive-in in Daytona
Beach it was on Nova Road and um ice to
go there as a kid all the time I
remember seeing scanners there yeah I
think I saw the Texas Chainsaw Massacre
that was like a read you know they reach
out it obviously cuz I was only two when
that [ __ ] came out my parents weren't my
parents weren't that cool I'm gonna -
you're holding SD Texas Chainsaw
Massacre do high school kids even have
cars nowadays though well yeah they do
okay why wouldn't they didn't have
motorcycles they still got to go to
[ __ ] school okay you know what I mean
yeah I didn't know what do you think
they fly or something today evolved
wings in the last couple generations
dick if I could just fly to school of
course she need a car I mean I didn't
have a car cuz I was poor but you know
what I mean most of my friends had cars
but yeah so what else did you have oh
you know what I mean you know what I was
gonna you know how we've like we're
doing music recommendations before and
should we used to keep doing that or can
you not think of anything right now I
can't think of anything because I was
coming in here the other day and I was
like I was taking pictures of my CD
collection I was gonna put that up on
Instagram then I was like well [ __ ] we
said we were gonna do that and then we
never did well well I did you know I
hadn't really prepared anything well cuz
like I said it's Sunday there's not a
hell of a lot going on I got the met in
a shoe show put up we're still watching
Kingdom
so like I said we probably won't review
that for the next week's matinee just
because we probably won't finish it in
time and you know it's easier just to do
because there's still look there's two
seasons and we're still only the first
season so we'll probably do the platform
sit because somebody recommended it
maybe VFW VFW maybe something else but I
don't know we'll see how it's gonna go
and we're definitely gonna do the Kurt
Russell movie we're gonna do for the
movie retrospective on Friday that's why
all right so it's two different things
the retrospective is the old movie and
the matinee is the three new movies okay
you know so that's what we're gonna do
all right so uh this was kind of short
and boring but we just wanted to check
in with you guys on Sunday and hope you
guys are still all doing okay out there
and we'll talk to you again tomorrow